but how joining us now with more Fox
News contributor and former Speaker of
the House n gingr you know speaker ging
it's it's always a pleasure to hear your
wisdom and at a moment in history where
Republicans you know we control the
house that's it we don't have the Senate
we don't have the presidency and we know
elections are about Choice how does the
house under newly elected speaker Mike
Johnson who I sat across from was very
impressed by how does the house give the
American people a choice illustrate a
contrasting agenda to BU and what should
they be
doing well I I think they're doing a lot
of it I think that if you look at the
bills they've been passing uh Aid to
Israel but offset by cutting money out
of the Internal Revenue Service a series
of steps a very strong parental rights
bill that virtually every Democrat voted
against I think there are a lot of steps
they can take but you also have to be
realistic I think what speaker Johnson
decided was that keeping the government
open was the Practical Next Step given
where they were and the mess that they'd
been in and I suspect that was right now
they're going to have some big fights
over Appropriations but in the long run
there are a lot of other things the
House Republicans are doing that are
going to end up mattering uh the fact is
that the uh Biden family increasingly
looks like in a newsletter recently I
called them the Delaware Sopranos uh we
get more evidence every week from people
like chairman comr and chairman Jordon
and chairman Smith every single week
we're getting more evidence that this is
just a family of crooks and that's an
important job which would not be
happening if the House Republicans
didn't have a majority so I think you're
going to see both uh the process of
legislation and the process of
Investigation moving forward but but let
me also be clear if if Biden can't
solve uh the challenge with Israel the
challenge with Ukraine The Challenge on
the border the challenge with fenel the
challenge with crime the challenge with
prices going up everywhere chist and I
were just out shopping yesterday and I
mean the the degree to which grocery
prices keep going up affects every
single American it's not about polling
it's not about advertising it's about
pain yeah you know nude and and the
famous old adage is it's the economy
stupid we've all heard that
but you know the counterargument to that
is the economy didn't seem to have as
much of an effect in the midterms as we
would have hoped but is it a different
beast when you're talking about a
presidential election do people more
directly tie the economy to the sitting
president will it matter in a way that
perhaps it didn't in the
midterms well I think the i' I've done a
lot of work on what happened in the
midterms and what happened just a week
ago and part of my conclusion is that
Republicans do not yet understand the
scale of the democratic machine when you
take the service employees union you
take the teachers union you take the
leftwing activist groups you take
billionaires like Soros the total weight
if you go State US Senate race by US
Senate race for example or narrow house
races or in Virginia some of the
legislative races we're just not big
enough we're like a midsize college team
in the Super Bowl and we're going to
have to really get a grip this year on
what are we going to do to offset the
sheer weight of left-wing money which is
desperately trying to retain control for
a practical reason Joe Biden is spending
6 trillion $200 billion annually wow now
if you're a leftwing union or a leftwing
interest group losing control of 6.2
trillion gets you pretty darn motivated
and that's a big part of what's going on
that's a fascinating description now
what happens when you put what you just
described that massive operation and
combine it with mail and balloting which
people might not realize but in a place
like Nevada they've codified their covid
era mail and ballot laws Mass mail out
voting to all of their voter roles so
what happens when you make that
combination well I think it's very
dangerous for the Republicans and very
dangerous for the country what you have
today is a Nationwide machine on the
left a machine made up of interest
groups I mean for example the New York
City Democrats are going to be asking
for billions to pay for uh Joe Biden's
illegal immigrants billions and they're
going to want the money uh the city of
Chicago the mayor is going to want
billions you go across the whole country
and what you see is interest group after
interest group that's going to want the
money what you have on the Republican
side are people who are really worried
about the the budget they really want to
get to a balance they want to save
Social Security and Medicare well all
those things are a direct threat to the
interest groups on the left now the
difference in a presidential race
particularly if Donald J Trump's
involved is he is such a huge figure he
is not a candidate he is the champion of
millions of Americans the leader of a
movement very different than anything
we've seen in most of American history
he can rise above no matter how much
money the left has he has the capacity
to reach the American people despite
them and you have to say as of tonight
he's certainly going to be the nominee
and the odds are much better than even
maybe three out of five or four out of
five that he'll be the next president
which as it sinks in is going to drive
the left crazy there's no doubt uh he
has a movement like we've never seen
which is why they must be deprogrammed
in the words of Hillary Clinton speaker
Gingrich thank you very much hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else